alors avec votre main gauche oui voilà
encore une
il y a encore quelques années il n'était
pas rare de voir des vignes en ile de
france et même à elancourt
aujourd'hui ces vendanges sont une
véritable fête pour la ville cela fait
26 ans que jean flattot a planté les
premiers pieds depuis ils oeuvrent
chaque année en maître de cérémonie
il ya des personnes nouvelles avec des
enfants en très bas âge je n'ai pu voir
la motivation malgré la bruine qui
tangue
c'est formidable mais heureux parce que
en fait les objectifs de l'association
c'est festif ça va être ta fête
pédagogique et ludique
j'ai eu le jeu et vous aviez des
petits-enfants que trois ou quatre ans
les yeux pétillaient transmettre son
savoir jean flattot en a fait son métier
puis sa passion professeur de physique
et mathématiques au lycée il se consacre
à l'histoire dès 1987 avec son
association les amis du passé
d'elancourt arrivé en 1973 dans la ville
il est maintenant une figure
incontournable et on peut dire comme la
ville je me suis enraciné mais j'ai
toujours mon pied droit en franche-comté
d'où viennent les pieds de vie de
charcenne dans la haute-saône
j'ai toujours été dans les associations
l'herbe c'est vrai que je peux le dire
aujourd'hui j'ai pas toujours drôle pour
la famille parce qu'on est souvent
absent et puis à partir de cet
engagement j'ai été aussi élu 19 ans et
demi il conseille maire-adjoint des
encours il aime sa vie il a tout un
réseau d'amis dire les amis du passé des
encours qui l'a créé
avec toutes une toute une équipe c'est
très important pour une commune ne pas
oublier ses racines
une équipe constituée d'une trentaine
d'adhérents qui s'occupe des vignes
chaque semaine après la récolte place au
pressage est au bilan
on dirait pas la récolte du siècle mais
pratiquement on a une récolte très
importante en quantité et voir en
qualité est là il ya sept rangs de vigne
et comme vous voyez derrière il ya eu
sept conteneurs remplis un de blanc elle
est si je ne reviens rouge et pour la
partie technique cette fois c'est joseph
gonthier qui préside
c'est lui le responsable de la section
vignes il a rejoint l'association il ya
cinq ans j'aime bien moi le côté je veux
dire pédagogique
il est bon de faire attention à la
transmission du savoir est en tout cas
de l'exemple les enfants sont étonnés
quand on leur dit que nous travaillons
pour eux en tant que bénévole une
découverte pour les enfants mais aussi
pour les adultes ses adhérents a pris
par eux-mêmes l'art de faire du vin une
expérience rendue possible grâce à
l'association et à son président c'est
un monsieur très déjà très sympathique
ouvert aux autres très tolérant chacun
s'entraide chacun amène sa pulsion et
puis petit à petit et ben ça crée
quelque chose de positif quoi après une
matinée de labeur une centaine de litres
de jus de raisin a été mis en fût il
sera mis en bouteille au mois de juin
mais les amis du passé d'elancourt ont
encore un grand événement à venir
en partenariat avec la ville jean flat
organise le premier salon du livre le 22
octobre 70 auteurs sont attendus à la
commanderie des templiers